[Music]
welcome back everyone so we're talking
about the Fourier series and how you can
approximate arbitrary periodic functions
by adding up sines and cosines of higher
and higher frequencies okay so in this
example what we're gonna do is we're
going to code this up in MATLAB to
approximate this triangular hat function
using the Fourier series okay so I have
the code already pre preloaded here you
can download all of these codes at
databook UW comm and they're also all on
github for both the MATLAB and the
Python versions okay so let's walk
through this the first thing we're gonna
do in this code is to define our domain
so in this case I'm going to define a
domain from negative PI to PI so kind of
L is is PI and I'm going to define my X
domain from minus L to L so minus PI to
PI with 1024 points and then I'm going
to define my hat function and the way
I'm defining this hat function is I'm
gonna chop this domain up into quarters
and the first quarter and the last
quarter are going to have a functional
value of zero and then the middle two
second and third quarters are going to
have a positive slope and a negative
slope to make this hat so that's what
you see right here okay and I'm just
gonna plot this for you okay so this is
our triangular hat function on the
domain negative pi to pi ax and now all
of kind of the interesting stuff happens
in this code here this is how we're
actually going to compute the Fourier
series and so I just wrote it out here I
wanted to remind you mathematically what
this is the Fourier series is a sum of
these Fourier coefficients a K and B K
times their corresponding cosine and
sine functions of increasing frequency
so as K goes up then the frequency of
these cosines and sines goes up also and
they get higher and higher frequency and
you obtain these coefficients a K and B
K by projecting your function into into
that basis or with that that particular
case cosine and case sine mode and this
this inner product here is really just a
dot product if these were data vectors
if these were
years of data evaluated at discrete
values X okay and that's exactly how
we're actually computing this in MATLAB
so what we do here the first thing I'm
going to do is I'm going to compute the
I guess this really should be K equals 0
there's a 0th mode here that's what I'm
computing here is just the inner product
of F with the constant cosine of 0
function which is just equal to 1
ok that's here and then what I'm gonna
do is for K equals 1 to 20 what we're
actually going to do is we're going to
approximate this we're going to
approximate this instead of a sum to
infinity what we're gonna do is we're
going to sum to 220 ok and that's not
going to be an exact representation of
our function but what you're gonna see
is that as you increase the order from
you know K equals 1 to 2 to 3 and so on
up to 20 you get a better and better
approximation of this of this function
okay so we're gonna add up k equals 1 to
20 modes and the first thing I'm going
to do is compute my a K and B K
coefficients by computing these blue
inner products here that's exactly what
I'm doing here so I'm literally taking
the dot product of F my function with
that K cosine and that case sine mode ok
and I have to normalize by like 1 over
pi and the DX ok so I have to I have to
normalize this inner product with my
Delta X and a 1 over PI on the outside
ok and then I just add up those case
terms in this sum this a K cosine K plus
B K sine of K and the last thing I'm
going to do is just plot it for you and
I have a little pause here so that every
time I increase the order from K equals
1 to 2 to 3 up to 20 you're gonna see a
new function pop up on the screen okay
so let's run this ok and you can see as
you increase the order you go from
yellow through red through dark blue to
light blue and as you keep increasing
the order of this Fourier series
approximation you get a better and
better and better approximation to this
sharp triangular hat function okay so
for K equals 1 you have
this kind of single single wave here not
a very good approximation but very
quickly as you increase the order you
start to to actually approximate this
function quite well so this is just a
nice example that shows you kind of how
you can approximate at least in this
case continuous function so this
function has has points but it is
continuous it doesn't jump at any
locations and so the Fourier series is
going to do a really nice job of
approximating this continuous periodic
function okay good now the last thing I
want to show you is plotting the
amplitudes so we have all of those a kbk
fourier coefficients or amplitudes of
the cosines and sines that I'm adding up
and I want to plot some of this stuff
for you so here I'm actually going to
compute the first hundred of those
Fourier coefficients so I'm gonna go
from one to two K max of 100 I'm not
gonna plot all of that but I am gonna
plot is versus the mode number so from k
equals zero to 100 what I'm gonna plot
is what is the mode amplitude kind of
what's the the magnitude of those
Fourier coefficients and how much error
is there in my reconstruction and I
think I just caught a small typo in my
code one second here okay divided by PI
I changed my code a little and I made it
a little bit nicer but I have to divide
out pi okay so let's make sure that this
so if you if you notice actually this
this code here is a little bit cleaner
than the code in the book and now let's
plot our amplitudes and I really hope
this works perfect okay good so now what
we have kind of our error performance
versus mode number and so this is what
you want you want this to be a
monotonically decreasing function you
want your reconstruction error kind of
how good of an approximation this sum is
to my function f you want that to
monotonically decrease as you add more
and more and more Fourier modes and
that's something you get for periodic
continuous functions is that you get
this monotonic decrease in error and
what that means is that if
I have a little bit more more
computation I can add a few more of
these modes I can get a little bit
better approximation a little bit lower
error and so this red dot here shows a
particular truncation I guess probably
here I'm truncating in about seven modes
something like that and you can see this
is the mode amplitude okay so it has
this interesting kind of oscillating
pattern but the mode error is just going
down and down and down and if this is on
a log scale so this is actually very
very low error even with a few modes
okay now this I find kind of interesting
is that the mode amplitude has this kind
of oscillating pattern every fourth
Fourier coefficient it gets very very
small and you can actually see that if
you walk through K equals 1 2 2 2 3 2 4
5 6 7 8 and so on and so forth every
fourth coefficient the function really
doesn't change very much the
approximation and the only way I can
really explain this is this is must be
have to do with some symmetry in this
particular function that I chose some
some kind of symmetry is manifesting
itself in a very very small force for a
coefficient ok but the upshot here is
that you can approximate functions that
are periodic and continuous very very
well with a truncated Fourier series ok
so we didn't even have to add up to you
know all infinite modes we truncate it
at mode 20 and we get a very very nice
approximation of our function ok so now
you know how to compute the Fourier
series kind of encode in MATLAB by
taking these inner products to get these
coefficients you can add up all those
cosines and sines and you get really
nice function approximations ok thank
you